المترجم: Meem Elnefeidi
المدقّق: Ahmad Altamimi
(الموسيقى السوداني التقليدية)
(طبلة)
بلاي قلت لي ناس البيت كيف
كويسين الحمد لله إنت كيف اخبارك
والحاصل عليك
تمام والله الحمد لله
الجديد؟!
والله ياهو ماشي الحال عايشين
كيف ناس البيت ؟
كويسين والله الحمد لله
وبتك كيف حسي؟
كويسة بخبر
كان عمرها كم ؟!
تسعة سنة
تسعة سنة...
كان عمري تسعة سنة
زيي زي أي بت عمرها تسعة سنة
كل همي العب وأحس إني حلوا
أجري وأعمل روج بالدس
الصاح والغلط بحددو امي وأبوي
هم كل حاجة, هم الدنيا, هم السعادة
هم اكتر ناس بتحبني و بتخاف علي
معقولة ,معقولة اكتر ناس بتحبني
تكون سبب أكبر الآمى!
دلوكه وصفقة زغاريد وغنا
انا كيف يعني عروس انا لسه صغيرة
البت بتكون عروس مرتين, يوم طهورا
ويوم عريسه
طيب عريسي منو؟؟؟
الليلة ماف عريس
بس في قروش كتيره وحنة وحلاوة وفستان جديد
قروش كتيره وحنة فستان جديد
وحنة سوداء زي حقت امي
مش زي البتعملها لينا حبوبه وتطلع حمراء
ياااااااااااه انا تاني دايرة شنو
ياتونة خلي ماما تختنك
عشان ناخد قروش كتيره
ونمشي الحديقة ونلعب
أي لازم يختنونا انا سمعتهم بقولوا
لو ما ختنونا لمن نكبر ما حنعرس
كل البنات في المدرسة كانوا مختونات
(طبلة)
ظلام ماف شي غير ظلام انا بحصل لي شنو؟
ديل منو؟ أنا ما فاهمة حاجة ؟؟
وينك يا يمه؟ وينك يا يابا؟ ليييييه؟ ليييه؟
ناس كتير بعرفهم وما بعرفهم
دلوكه وصفقة وغنا
فستاني الجديد باظ.. انا بكره فستاني...
بكره الحنة بكره الغنا!!
انا ليه بيحصل لي كدا؟ عملتا شنو ؟؟
(موسيقي)
بتذكروا كأنوا امبارح..
بسأل نفسي كتير لوكان جريت اليوم داك وشردت؟
كان حيحصل لي كدا؟
ولا لو كان عاينت في عيون يمه وقلت يما لا
حبك لي أكبر وخوفك علي أكبر !!
وانت يابا يرضيك؟ يرضيك
بتك الدلوعة يحصل فيها كدا؟
معقول، معقول بعد كل العذاب الشفتوا
والألم العشتوا ختنت بتي!! هل حتسامحني ؟؟
واسامح نفسي كيف؟؟
كيف؟ كيف انا سمعت كلام الناس!
كيف ختنت بتي؟
بتي واعية ومسؤولة .. دا شرف شنو؟
دا جهل وسخف!!
"انا ندمان عشان..
انا ندمان عشان سمعت الاهل والجيران
وخفت من الكلام وانتهكت الحق اللازم يتصان"
عشان انا بت؟
عشان انا عيب؟
عشان انا غلط؟
عشان انا حرام؟
(الرقصة)
أكبر جرح جواي لسه عايش... طيب هو؟؟
بكرة أقول ليهو شنو ؟؟ حيكون رد فعلوا شنو؟
إتألمت قدر شنو؟؟؟
قصد جسدياً
بت تسعة سنة عشرة يوم ما قادرة تقوم ولا تلعب
بس الجرح الجواي عمرو ما برى!
عمري ما نسيت اليوم داك
ومن بعدها كرهت جسمي
واحبوا كيف وهو ما حقي ؟؟
هم تقيل لازم ادفع ثمنوا
ست البنات زي ما دايماً وقفت معاي
دي فرصتي عشان اقيف معاك
مع بعض حنتخطى كل شيء
حنسعد بعض و نحب بعض,
بحبك زي ما انتي و مهما كنتي
صاحباتي واخواتي وناسي القراب
انا معاك..يمكن انا ما مختونة
بس لمن سمعت قصتك حسيت بألمك وجرحك ومعاناتك
انا معاك وحأقيف معاك
(موسيقي)
أكبر وأوعى وأعرف
انا ما عيب ولا غلط!!
جسمي ما حق زول !!
أكبر وأوعى وأعرف! أنسى الفات؟ بقدر؟؟
ما عارفة؟؟ بس بقدر الليلة أقيف ..
.. وبقدر اكون اقوى
ولو في يوم جبت بت حأحبها زي ما أمي حبتني..
حأوعيها وأعلمها وأكبرها أنا ما حأختن بتي
انا ما حأختن بتي... انا حأحبها وأحميها
انا فعلاً اقوى من كل الحصل لي
بيدي أكون الأنا عايزاه
جسمي (ملكي)
فكري (ملكي)
يومي (أمسى)
غدي (وحياتي)
(عواطفي) قراري
ملكي
ملكي انا بس
أنا لن